nadie leyó un libro de pasta pasta en
una sola sesión a una tasa de 55 páginas
por hora después de leer por 4 horas le
quedaban 330 páginas pendientes por leer
y tenemos 2 preguntas cuántas páginas
tenía el libro y cuánto tiempo le llevó
a nao ya leer el libro entero muy bien
así que como siempre hay un montón de
formas de resolver este ejercicio así
que te invito a que hagas una pausa y
trates de hacerlo por tu propia cuenta
con algún método que se te ocurra
y por ejemplo yo voy a hacerlo de una
forma y luego lo abordaré de una segunda
forma primero voy a hacer una tabla
digamos que vamos a hacer una tabla
donde del lado izquierdo tengamos el
tiempo y vamos a medirlo en horas muy
bien ese sería el lado izquierdo de
nuestra tabla y del lado derecho voy a
poner el número de páginas restantes así
que voy a poner leer 'por restantes y
esto vamos a medirlo en páginas ok r me
dice cuántas páginas restantes le quedan
a la olla por leer así que por ejemplo
cuando va empezando a leer
tendremos bueno no sabemos cuántas
páginas restantes le quedan verdad si
supiéramos tendríamos ya la respuesta de
cuántas páginas tenía el libro porque
dice que empieza a leer el libro digamos
desde desde el mero principio del libro
así que esta pregunta es bastante
interesante porque no sabemos cuántas
páginas tiene el libro muy bien ahí
tenemos esta información entonces
tampoco sabremos
cuántas páginas habrá restantes por leer
después de una hora ni después de dos
horas ni después de tres horas sino
hasta la cuarta hora verdad porque nos
dice que después de cuatro horas le
quedaban 330 páginas restantes por leer
pero nosotros podemos hacer un análisis
un poco más detallado porque sabemos que
la olla lee a 55 páginas por hora verdad
entonces cada hora que nosotros
incrementamos verdad si consideramos
nuestro cambio en el tiempo y si ese
cambio en el tiempo de una hora verdad
recordemos que este triangulito en
realidad es la letra griega delta y
representa a cambio si el cambio en el
tiempo es de una hora entonces vamos a
tener un cambio en el número de páginas
restante verdad y si leímos más páginas
quiere decir que nos quedan menos
páginas restantes por leer verdad
cuantas tendríamos entonces a la hora
tres de de haber empezado a leer bueno
pues sí
aumentar una hora tenemos 55 páginas
menos verdad aquí tendríamos un aumento
o bueno el cambio en nuestras páginas
restantes es de menos 55 páginas aunque
por qué pues porque disminuye el número
de páginas restantes que nos quedan por
leer verdad entonces al regresar
tendríamos que sumar 55 verdad
tendríamos entonces 385 páginas
restantes verdad al aumentar una hora
entonces leemos 55 páginas lo cual nos
deja ahora en 330 y es consistente con
lo que teníamos abajo entonces qué
pasaría a la segunda hora bueno
tendríamos que sumarle a 385 tendríamos
que sumarle 55 verdad entonces si le
sumamos 5 nos da 390 y si ahora le
sumamos 50 nos da 440 a la primera hora
entonces tendríamos que nuevamente sumar
55 verdad y eso son 4
95 y lo último sería sumarle 55 a 495
entonces si le sumamos 5 nos da 500 y si
sumamos 50 nos da 550 entonces la
respuesta a cuántas páginas tiene el
libro es 550 páginas verdad porque
porque empezamos a leerlo desde el
inicio más bien nosotros no sino nao ya
empezó a leer el libro desde el inicio y
aquí nos dice que en el inicio había 550
páginas restantes por leer lo cual nos
dice el número de páginas totales que
tiene el libro ahora la segunda pregunta
es cuánto tiempo le le llevó a nao ya
leer el libro entero así que para saber
eso no sea una estrategia que podríamos
seguir es continuar esta tabla por
ejemplo qué pasaría a las cinco horas
bueno a las 5 horas leyó 55 páginas más
de estas que ya tenía verdad entonces
habría que restarle ahora sí
y cinco a330 y eso nos da 275 verdad por
ejemplo si le sumamos 55 nos da si
sumamos 5 nos da 280 si sumamos 50 nos
da 330 entonces está bien y así
podríamos seguir nos hasta llegar a 0
páginas restantes sin embargo puede ser
muy tardado así que vamos a hacerlo de
otra forma fijémonos muy bien por
ejemplo tenemos 12 300 330 páginas
ok tenemos 330 páginas aquí en esta
cuarta hora y nosotros leemos o más
dignado ya lee a 55 páginas por hora
páginas por hora esta división lo que
nos dice es cuántas horas tarda en leer
estas 330 páginas verdad y esto lo
podemos calcular fácilmente esto es 330
330 páginas vamos a ponerlo así 330
páginas por 1 entre 55 verdad
simplemente estamos expresando esta
división como una multiplicación sería
multiplicar por el recíproco de ésta
de esta cantidad verdad y el recíproco
estaría dada en horas entre páginas
muy bien la ventaja que es que las
páginas se cancelan y simplemente nos
queda 330 entre 55 horas muy bien y esto
es bueno sería más o menos 6 verdad 6
por 5 son 30 lo cual nos da 336 por 5
son otros 30 y más 300 nos da 330
entonces está muy bien estos son 6 horas
muy bien son 6 horas y tú estarías a lo
mejor muy tentado a responder que son 6
horas lo que le llevó a nao ya leer el
libro entero pero hay que tener mucho
cuidado porque estas seis horas son a
partir de este momento a partir de este
momento que le faltan 330 páginas verdad
así que si leyó seis horas más después
de estas cuatro en total le llevo 10
horas leer el libro completo así que
veamos brevemente si es consistente
nosotros tendríamos inicialmente 550 y
550 páginas y si lo leemos
en 10 horas entonces 550 entre 10 nos da
55 páginas por hora que era justamente
la tasa de lectura que teníamos al
inicio verdad 55 páginas por hora muy
bien ahora vamos a resolverlo de otra
forma y la forma en la que quiero
resolverlo es viendo que esto es la
función r lo podemos expresar como una
función lineal verdad podríamos expresar
r dt como el número de páginas restantes
después de haber leído t horas verdad
rd t bueno pues es una expresión lineal
es una función lineal con una tasa de
cambio o una pendiente de menos 55 menos
55 es la tasa de cambio verdad leemos o
más bien la hoya lee a una tasa de 55
páginas por hora así que cada hora que
avanza tenemos menos o menos páginas
pendientes por leer así que esta es la
tasa de cambio que multiplica el número
de horas
verdad es nuestra variable independiente
y hay que sumarle vez donde ves la
ordenada al origen o bien el número de
páginas restantes que tenemos al tiempo
inicial al tiempo cero verdad entonces
nosotros ya sabemos que son 550 pero
vamos a suponer que no lo que no lo
sabemos que estamos iniciando el
problema así que la forma en la que
podemos obtener be es con este dato de
aquí nosotros podemos utilizar que al
tiempo 4 le quedan 330 páginas verdad
entonces si nosotros ponemos de igual a
tendremos pendientes 330 páginas verdad
así que lo que hay que resolver es 330
igual a menos 55 menos 55 vamos a
ponerlo con este color menos 55 por 4
que son menos 220 verdad 5 por 4 son 20
y 5 por 4 son otros 20
son 200 más 20 ahí lo tenemos y hay que
sumarle ve hay que sumarle ve que es lo
que no conocemos muy bien así que para
despejar ve podríamos sumar de ambos
lados 220 más 200 pips son 220 de este
lado se cancelan pero del lado izquierdo
tenemos son 550 verdad entonces b es
igual a 550 y era justamente lo que ya
teníamos verdad así que la función
r rt de las páginas restantes se escribe
como menos 55 t más 550 muy bien por
supuesto el número de páginas restantes
es igual
más bien el número de páginas restantes
al tiempo cero es decir al inicio es el
número de páginas que tiene el libro
verdad pero al tiempo cero esto se
cancela y simplemente nos queda 550 así
que con esto ya podríamos resolver la
primera pregunta verdad son 550 páginas
las que tiene el libro ahora bien como
podríamos resolver el tiempo que le
llevó a la hoya leer el libro entero
bueno pues estamos buscando un tiempo
para el cual el número de páginas
restantes sea cero verdad eso significa
que ya acabamos el libro y si tenemos
cero igual a menos cincuenta y cinco
temas 550 entonces sumando de ambos
lados 55 te tenemos 55 de igual a 550 y
podemos dividir de ambos lados entre 55
tendremos 550 entre 55 y esto es
exactamente 10 horas verdad de hecho
esto lo podríamos haber hecho desde un
inicio
en el problema anterior bueno pero como
ves hay muchas formas de resolver este
problema y eso es lo bonito de las
matemáticas solo son una forma de
representar cómo pensamos las cosas como
pensamos la realidad así que podemos
tener distintas maneras de representarla
utilizando tal vez distintos símbolos